rodney this is a guest we've been
waiting on for a long time now and your
former defensive coordinator and coach
pease i gotta
out of respect i'm gonna let you have
the first question here rod
well first let me just say this man dean
pease was such a i mean all the players
loved dean because he was so
easy to talk to he was so humble and
just so smart but he wasn't so smart
where he he didn't think that he can get
input from the players
so coach i just had to say that i
appreciate you how's retirement going
that's my first question
hey you know hey it's a it's tough time
right now with all the covered stuff
but everybody's going through it and
we'll get through it
and uh getting a lot of golf in i'll say
that
we look at the the titans pass rush and
today ben clowney
they just they just don't have any pass
rush what i mean
what would you do this year to try would
you add an extra linebacker would you
come up with more creative blitzes but
how can the titans this year get more
pressure on the quarterback coach
well i think they were trying a little
bit more last week in a way
that you know um
it's it's probably gonna have to get
manufactured it's it's hard to do it
with just four guys because i don't know
that we got the four guys but
i do say jeffrey simmons and daquan
jones those guys can push the middle
pretty good
um harold landry's a pretty good edge
guy we just they could use another edge
guy if you want to get a four-man rush
to me the biggest way is is to do
simulated pressures you know that's what
we did a lot last year
we felt good about uh the thing about
the simulated pressures
is you can if you once you learn the
protections and you can break them down
and know you can attack them
then you can really attack them with
four guys just bringing different guys
and dropping different guys and still
get maximum coverage
and i think you got to be careful a
little bit playing man coverage all the
time because that you know they're gonna
they catch on to that and they're doing
a lot of stuff to beat the man coverage
so you've got to manufacture it rodney i
mean i think with who we have it's kind
of like we did last year
coach lamar jackson you know so many of
these young next generation of
quarterbacks around the nfl
yeah they can run yeah they can do
incredible things with their legs they
can throw two
when you think about trying to stop this
group of guys i know you had some
chances to try to do so
what's the most challenging part about
these quarterbacks that can really do
both at such a high level
you know what one of the things is and
we made this
motto last year and secondary coach
called me this week and told me they
they used the same thing this year is
that when you're playing a lamar
jackson for example you want to capture
him
not try and kill him if you come up
there and try to really shoot your gun
and go after him that guy is so
quick he's gonna dodge it sometimes you
gotta give up
a yard or two to maybe not give up 20.
you know like even when you spine last
last year the only big run we gave to
him was we
we were spying him but the guy that was
firing him kind of shot his guns
as soon as lamar took a shot step to one
side he shot in there
and then all of a sudden lamar comes out
the other side you just gotta wait
and then then you hey yeah you're gonna
give up a four yard run
but those are not gonna kill you and i
thought they did a good job
this last weekend just like we did kind
of in the playoffs we gave up that one
but we kept running him to the sideline
and using
the sideline as the 12th defender and
really
just just don't give up the big one so
sometimes you know i used to say that
one like we used to play against welker
and little receivers uh
going against him one you know when i
went against him
at baltimore when he was still with the
patriots don't try and kill the guy
because he you're going to he don't make
you miss just tackling
and sometimes that's the way with some
of these quarterbacks too is quit trying
to get the big hit
just get the guy on the ground big ben's
the same way
i mean he's a different kind of guy
because he's so big just
tackling don't try and kill him you're
not going to kill it
well coach i've had the great pleasure
for these few weeks of being a teammate
of rodney harrison it's one of my
favorite things to do because he'll
always tell you exactly what he thinks
that's my favorite part about it
how about any great stories of coaching
the great rodney harrison
i tell you what here's the thing about
rodney is that
what he said was true and i learned it
early on from him and a bunch of those
guys with the patriots brewski all those
guys
look they're out there playing the game
they know more the coaches know
they do they see it all the time you
need to get their input
their coaches on the field they are i
mean it's different than college or high
school where you got to really tell
everybody kind of what to do
if you don't listen to them you're
really making a big mistake
and you know you used to have what i
call a signal callers meeting and i'd
have four or five guys in there
tell them here's the game plan and i
want to see their reaction
and i did it at baltimore with ray lewis
and suggs and hello denata and those
guys and
said hey here's the game plan what do
you think ed reed what do you guys think
if you don't like it i sure as heck
don't want to be calling it
i mean i want what you guys want to
we're all in this thing together this is
a
collaborated effort yeah i'm the coach
but you're the guys that got to play
here's the thing i loved about rodney we
had a situation
in new england where i had brandon
merriweather as a safety james sanders
is a safety and i had rodney
i could put rodney in at linebacker and
play money linebacker
i could move him out the next play to
nickel and play big nickel
and i can move him back to safety on
certain calls that's unbelievable
flexibility that was the year that you
know in 2007 we went undefeated
you could move those guys around and
rodney gave us that ability the other
two guys were really safeties
but rodney gave me the ability i
remember one time we did a simulated
pressure at dallas
and it was only a four-man rush and he
ended up beating uh witten in the
backfield they even went
max protection and romney beat the guy
and sacked romo
just on a simulated rush but he was came
from the nickel and then the next minute
i may have him with money and the next
minute he may be a safety
he gave us incredible flexibility on
that defense
and i've kind of used that ever even at
baltimore i used it with with other guys
i learned it from rodney coach pease
this has been such a great visit we
really appreciate you taking some time i
don't know how bored you've gotten with
the whole quarantine thing you think
about this tv stuff too really
appreciate you taking a minute here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports